voilà donc bienvenu bienvenu.merci est
bienvenu pas vous dire ce septième grand
prix des chèques de bordeaux en première
pour les matches de ce grand prix qui va
en comporter beaucoup je me plais 8
voilà huit matches huit matchs donc
c'est le premier des quarts de finale de
ce septième grand prix des chèques de
bordeaux alors pour ceux qui
découvriraient le grand prix je sais pas
si il ya des nouveaux arrivants
aujourd'hui vous avez sans doute un
casque pour écouter les commentaires
donc vous pouvez le régler avec avec le
bouton de fréquences et vous pouvez donc
écouter les commentaires qui seront
données en cabine par renault lagune ici
qui nous attend là-bas et moi même et en
attendant vous devriez entendre
et bien ce que ce que je dirais micro et
ainsi qu'une musique musique de fond
voilà donc pour vérifier qu'on vous
entende et bien voilà donc alors on va
démarrer sans tarder parce qu'on a pris
un tout petit peu de retard puisque des
moines benita est arrivé un peu in
extremis début un petit 10 ou si un
petit peu de souci c'est vrai que c'est
difficile actuellement dans bordeaux de
circuler en voiture et donc ils
connaissaient pas maintenant il le sait
il vaut mieux prendre le tram
voilà donc que nous sommes à bordeaux
pour ce septième grand prix des chèques
qui comme vous savez le spectacle qui
vulgarise tente de vulgariser les échecs
et le rendre accessible au plus grand
nombre et donc nous allons ici suivre
les matchs sur cet écran géant ici où
nous pourrons en même temps que nous
commentons les parties m'ont très bien
sûr sur l'écran allumé des cases vous
montrer des flèches aussi en même temps
pour illustrer les commentaires et alors
pour ce premier match que nous allons
démarrer sans tarder nous allons
recevoir deux grands champions
alors tout d'abord le premier il est
maître international il est présent à ce
grand prix parce qu'il a gagné l'open
des vins de naujac l'an dernier
naujac qui est donc comme vous savez à
côté d'oriens ici dans les docks il ya
un camping en camping à rochette qui est
partenaire de ce grand prix et qui
organise chaque année un open
international qui a lieu début début
juillet et qui donc a été gagné la
dernière passe l'année dernière par ce
joueur par ce maître international il
vient de lyon
il est donc maître international je vous
demande d'applaudir le maître
international yoann béni taiwan benita
folio un peu voilà peut-être juste un
petit mot tu arrivé un peu in extremis
c'était chaud
[Musique]
tu vois quand même être arrivé de
concentrer pour vous pour ce grand match
tu t'es tu préparé face aux joueurs
[Musique]
voilà donc qui les préparent et yoann
benita on aura l'occasion sans doute en
parler lors des commentaires
alors pour affronter lens benita et bien
c'est un grand champion qui vit en
france il luxembourgeois
c'est un très grand champion deux fois
vainqueur du championnat beau pari il
est grand maître international a déjà
fait partie des 100 meilleurs mondiaux
je vous demande d'applaudir le grand
maître international
alberto ben ali deux jours alberto
alors préparez aussi pour ce match
oppose une petite préparation quand même
grosse préparation voilà vous n'aurez
donc pour roberto david qui est très
élevé de tous les joueurs tous les
genres france est un joueur très très
sympathique président de tous les
français alors peut arbitrer ce match je
vous laisserai ensuite avec lui et bien
c'est l' arbitre régional et aussi
nationale pour la première fois leur
litre à un tournoi de cette de ce niveau
là et nous sommes très contents de
l'accueillir pour la première fois en
tant qu'arbitre il était déjà venu en
tant que spectateur maintenant il va
arbitrer les très connus ici en gironde
c'est l' arbitre national et
international
patrick et baisse patrick besse merci
doit tenir voilà je vous laisse seuls
trois semaines
merci stéphane bonjour à tout le monde
nous allons donc procéder au tirage au
sort de joueurs qui commencera le match
avec la couleur blanche
je vous rappelle que c'est un match en
deux parties 20 minutes par joueur
le match retour est la partie retour en
inversera des couleurs en cas d'égalité
nous aurons deux vite le départage
les retours et si il y à nouveau une
égalité nous aurons ce nous appelons une
mort subite
les blancs auront quatre buts pour
gagner et les moires 30 minutes en 3
nuls et monsieur benita a remporté l'or
il commencera donc cette partie avec les
blancs voilà donc ça va être à nous donc
bonjour nous bonjour c'était une fan
alors si vous vous entendez lever la
main voilà donc c'est bientôt vous
entendez donc nous sommes si en cabine
pour commenter son grand match de ce
septième grand prix il échec de bordeaux
alors il faut que la connectique voilà
ça y est mise en place et nous allons
voir les premiers coups voilà c'est
parti
c'est partie des 4 a été jouée par sarah
est allé assez vite un peu au début
alors tout de suite renault quel est ce
genre de début ça ressemble un début du
puits en dames et donc une défense est
indienne seco caractéristiques de
référence est indienne et je pense la
variante de ses miches estany pourquoi
les tiendront en fait c'est
essentiellement parce que ce fou et
développer du côté est
oui voilà sur l'ale est de l'échiquier
et alan viennent passer des joueurs
indiens qui qui les premières les années
1850 et quelqu'un avait joué ce type de
défense alors
on en saura donc de rendre sa niche est
caractérisée par ce coup ci est de f3
pour moi qui sert à consolider les
centres ares guidée de cette variante
c'est pour les blancs de tenir ici le
centre fortement oui d'avoir un centre
solide et puis de généralement à faire
le grand roque et de d'attaquer le roi
noir avec des poussées com hk jay 4 h 5
ouvertures on montre en même temps
renault les coûts parce que évidemment
s'il ya des joueurs parmi dans la salle
qui sont pas versées forcément un échec
donc c'est bien aussi de montrer un peu
les évidemment les coûts et de ceux qui
nous regardent aussi renault qui s'en va
laissant d'enregistrer sur des gones al
tv donc on peut dire bonjour à nos
téléspectateurs alors bonjour donc ici
on montre évidemment c'est pousser de
plus possible donc on tient le centre
avec les blancs donc on appelle temps
intro de bouger parce que je vois en
jouer très vite dans ces des grands
maîtres ils sont très préparé on est
jeune centre avec les blancs à ce gros
centres et les noirs pas ça va très vite
encore les noirs sont déjà préparés à
réagir sur ce relais dames un joueur
tourbe et 8 a rejoint à six et ils sont
prêts à ouvrir des lignes sur les dames
place que le roi essaiera d trouvait à
la voyez donc ils veulent donc c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont minato en v8 s'est
préparé la poussée des seins pour
préparer cette poussée pendant ces 4 et
ouvrir la colombie pour avoir du temps
de jeu
alors le dernier coup des noix en sites
intéressants en renault puisqu'il a le
gâteau david cherche à empêcher
justement les variantes que tu disais
j'ai cadre là il veut freiner il veut
freiner l'expansion des blancs sur sur
les leroy donc sinon crise aiguë c'est
une variante aiguë ces deux joueurs au
style batak c22 fort tacticien tous les
deux qu'ils calculent vite et juste ici
donc y renonce à faire le grand roque
il va laisser son roi centre ce qui se
produit quelques fois dans ce type de
position va rappeler aux noms qu'on
aurait pu faire le grand roque c'est de
remettre le roi de deux cases et mètres
la tour sur la casse d un ouais mais qui
s'il est blanc comme ils ont joué le
pourtour csa et laurent n'est plus
possible puisque quand on a joué la tour
où le roi on a ça y est on ne peut plus
rauque et en persan sans droit du rotor
pourquoi les
n'ont pas fait le drop probablement
qu'ils ont eue pour justement que les
noirs ouvrant les colonnes se met une
tour face quasiment au roi blanc voilà
parce que les noirs aurait été sans
doute les premiers à ouvrir des lignes
du côté où le roi avait trouvé un abri
sûr les dames donc il va éviter de
mettre son rang danger sur les dames il
va laisser son roi au centre parce que
justement ce centre il est solidifié
avec le le pire en f3 qui défend le
cadre le cavalier c3 qui défend le 4 et
le pion des quatre et qui est bien
défendu un centre fort puissant et
solide
alors notez que ça va être un peu
difficile pour yoann benita kit qui a eu
du mal à trouver le théâtre en fait un
carnet de l'ue ont directement en
voiture et qui en fait est peut-être
aura peut-être des premières rentrées
dans le match parce qu'il sait ouais
mais il les a pressés pourront pour
arriver il doit avoir sa petite idée
c'est à dire que le système qui qu'il
joue là il a dû y réfléchir le pratiquer
sans doute d'avoir une expérience dessus
et donc c'est une manière de surprendre
aussi son adversaire avec le coutour
c'est en et puis le fait de laisser le
roi au centre ce qui ne se fait pas
toujours dans ce type de position alors
à noter aussi alors pour alberto david
qu'il a choisi donc l'estonienne cette
variante ester dean qui n'est plus à la
mode qui n'était plus à la mode depuis
quelques années parmi les meilleurs
joueurs mondiaux et qui était un peu
remise au goût du jour par radjabov au
tournoi chorus récemment voilà les
russes ont toujours mls l'indienne ils
ont beaucoup étudié beaucoup pratiqué
mais qui était tombé en désuétude depuis
quelques années depuis les variantes
avait lobé 4 et puis les attaques sur
sur les nerfs mais qui allait très vite
donc les noirs avaient un peu abandonné
le stadion puis elle revient à la mode
voilà ce qui est intéressant de voir
c'est ce coup cavaliers des 5 parce que
le cavalier est fortement donc installé
au centre et un peu montré là on va
montrer renault toutes les cases que
cela valait contrôle et surtout en cas
de des changes par parlotte cavaliers
bien ce serait le plan c qui reprendrait
ouvrir la colonne c'est à la tour c'est
pour ça qu'il a placé la transfère on va
montrer ça je suis juste enlevé ma belle
étoile de cavaliers effectivement si les
blancs si les noirs prenez ici cavaliers
prend cavaliers ce qui est possible
parce que la pression maintenant s'ils
réussissent est forte quand même mais si
on n'échange pas ce cavalier il reste
prendre pioncer sarr centre et la tour c
se voit ouvrir une belle colonnes avec
le pion c7 en ligne de mire 1% trop de
pions en plus très puissant voilà et
puis un thème c'est facile à exploiter
le fameux pied arrière et sur la colonne
ouverte de bien c'est 7 qui serait
rirait sur la colline c'est à ce feu
option qui servirait de faiblesse tapez
par la tour donc le cavalier blanc on
pèse sur la position et les noirs
doivent trouver quelque chose puisque le
leur plan naturel qui est l expansion
allait même où se serait réfugié le roi
n'a pas vraiment lieu d'être alors le
problème pour les blancs c'est quand ils
sont le roi au centre pour l'instant
leur tour à chiens ici ne joue pas c'est
tout est un peu hors jeu et puis le roi
n'a pas vraiment d'abris sur les pieds
en sang a lancé il ya peu de de pas mal
de cases accessible au noir pour une
phase ultérieure en plus tard dans la
partie
le roi n'aura pas de vrais abri là au
centre alors un coup logique ici dans le
marteau david donc il enlève la pression
qui avait pas ce que la menace des
blancs s'étaient 30 ans m6 et sur
l'emprise du fonds prenait ensuite ils
ont créé des pions doublé voilà
peut-être une menace et là on voit
qu'elle achète donc ils empêchent 7
en tout cas cette manoeuvre et la tacle
fou aussi ce qui serait sans doute une
bonne affaire pour les noirs de prendre
ce fou g5 et là on peut se poser la
question est ce que les banques peuvent
tous les coups qui paraît naturel le
couple russe 6 protégé par la dame des
2sous ainsi se proposerait des changes
et le fou g7 qui défendront en noir oui
c'est un coût possible d'ailleurs ça
doit être l'idée de bénite puisqu'il a
joué cavalier 2 pour défendre le pied en
d4
il le fait voilà il avait joué cavalier
deux pour jouer faux âge si c'est pour
que le pire des quatre soit pas en l'air
en cas d'échangé 1 h 6 ce pion ici bon
l'assomption n'est pas en l'air ils ont
dit pendant l'heure si le cavalier c'est
pas ça qui l'a mille cavaliers aux deux
prix pour satisfaire un mois d'abord
parce que sinon il y avait deux pièces
noires qui tapait non mais il y avait au
prince cissé puisqu'elle va les prendre
des quatre plus tard donc là si si on
arrivait à changer tous les sept ils
peuvent envisager de sacrifier un pion
aussi par angers car trois essais c'est
une attaque thématique ce contre cette
structure
ils ont un pion et on ne leur prend pas
car de prison joue très vite h5 pour
ouvrir la colonne h pour la tour agen
et avoir une pièce lourdes braqués sur
sur le roi noir ont dit à andy en
général que une tour qui vise un roi
avec une colonne verte vaut l'équivalent
d'un pion donc on peut très bien donner
un pion pour ouvrir sans voir donald
savoie les noirs seraient obligés de
prendre à vous serez ensuite à 5
voilà c'est un des thèmes adapte ac mais
l'état lui est un joueur d'attaqué a pas
peur de donner un petit peu de matériel
comme tous les joueurs de l'attak pour
avoir un des pièces active du jeu et un
naître le roi de verre sans danger alors
là pendant le dernier coup d'oeil par
tous d'avis de pose de questions
cavaliers où va ce cavalier voile alors
c'est très classique ça c'est à dire que
sa taille cavaliers son plus grand
ennemi comme la plupart des pièces c'est
le pion et donc la case des cinq étant
impeccable par un pion n'était pas une
case stable pour le cavalier donc qui me
les a expulsés de cette case
alors il fait celles jouées par action b
5 réactions b 5 donc il va ouvrir
il a chassé la puissante pièces blanches
du centre et maintenant ils se préparent
à agir sur l'ale d'âme parce que il sait
que lui aussi s'il voit des lignes il
pourra s'approcher du virois noir alors
brice prise melita bien fait de prendre
parce que en prenant deux pions
renforcer encore en revenir sur la
colombe et la colombie n'est pas
accessible à la tour puisqu'elle a un
pur noir devant elle
donc la menace des noirs sans doute de
jouer des quatre toujours attaquant ce
cavalier qui va avoir du mal à trouver
des cases sans doute voilées alors
maintenant doivent réfléchir à la
poussée g4 voilà tu as l'air quand même
dangereuse bien sûr mais faut pas
oublier la sécurité du roi un jour bien
sûr mais quand il ya deux chasseurs
ainsi si le ch le blanc le joueur blanc
est un chasseur et le joueur noir à
chasseurs
ça sent comme chasseur de roi c'est le
plus habile techniquement qui est qui
impose sa loi par rapport à l'autre
joueur dont classer ces deux joueurs
très actif très tacticien donc il va y
avoir une belle empoignade
ça va vous donner une belle partie d'
attaque il peut y avoir d'autres plans
aussi d'autres idées pour les blancs
c'est de jouer aussi
cavalli et scarlett par exemple pourquoi
pas il portait un sacrifice en acheter
oui pourquoi pas avec des idées genre
tourache trois tours g3 wave battu le
roi
pourquoi pas les cases et noir ont été
très affaiblie par la disparition du fou
de cases noires des noirs 1 c'est l'idée
mais c'est l'idée du coin où haïti ce
qui changeait le fou g7
voilà on a éliminé un défenseur droit le
plan là le problème d'une adams et que
le matin rarement seul et donc il faut
amener des renforts il faut que
les cavaliers ou le food cases blanches
viennent soutenir la berme s'il avait le
teint de jouer j'ai quatre cavaliers g3
puis foulée 3 s'ils pouvaient jouer tous
ces trois coups à la fois et braquer ses
pièces sur le roi il aurait de bonnes
chances d'attac mais aux échecs c'est un
coup après l'autre au niveau du temps 13
minutes abstrait minutes à benita contre
14 à david donc égalité donc pas de pas
de problème pour l'instant c'est des
matchs en partie don de 20 minutes par
joueur
donc ça c'est la première partie dans la
première manche donc si c'est pas
certainement alberto david qui a gagné
le tirage au sort puisqu'il a choisi des
noirs on choisit souvent les noirs que
tomber le tirage au sort puisque ça
permet est bien adapté son jeu ensuite
car si on a perdu et bien on peut jouer
pour l'attack font alors que si on a
fait nul on peut gérer une attaque
mesuré voilà voilà en tout cas on sait
on connaît le résultat le plus difficile
à obtenir ses dires le résultat avec les
pièces noires alors maintenant est ce
que comme au football c'est le match
aller ouais match aller à l'extérieur
avec 1 c'est comme ça oui alors le
problème de du coup j'ai quatre voilà ce
qui va jouer le losc il a essayé
d'ouvrir mon jean perrault fichiers raw
non c'est que si les blancs jouent g4
puis on prend g4 sur le courage simple
et noir pourrait bloquer par g5
simplement il ya plus de colonne ouverte
voilà ça se fait très souvent ce type de
défense
et c'est parce que la dame blanche qui
est enfermé voilà on est vite on évite
les ouvertures de lignes et donc
peut-être il il faut avant de préparer
avant de jouer gk peut-être préparer
c'est pour ça qu'il n'a pas joué tout de
suite et atempo parce qu'il ya peut-être
ce problème là et a une autre idée aussi
tout ça encore peut-être encore plus
simple sur gée 4h pranger 4 h 5 au lieu
de juger cinq les noirs pour rejouer le
coup dame g5
une fois que le qui ont été injustement
et proposer les charges et d'ailleurs on
échange les dames du cool attaque
et quasiment tombe à l'eau tout de suite
oui mais à ce moment là qui est mieux à
bas prix sans ça il faut que le petit
centre retenu la d66 contre le forces
entre des 4,4 et yann briet que leur
coût surprenant de benita oui il joue
autour des 1 parce qu'il veut utiliser
sans cavalier de autre chose qu'à là un
cas la défense de d4 pourrait le mettre
en c1
non je pense qu'il veut le mettre
peut-être tu veux dire que le tour à
tour expliqué oui voila je vois j'ai
compris ce que tu voulais dire la tour
ici ont des seins protège le pied en a
éclaté dans la libère le camaïeu de la
défense de celui de la défense des clubs
là que ça devient des pièces mineurs
comme peut amener sur les droits sans
perdre le pied en d4 qui est important
c'est fameux thème de la surprotection
wayne surprotège une faiblesse ça permet
de libérer toutes les pièces du coup se
sentent beaucoup plus libres douala
alors maintenant ce cavalier doit
trouver une case
ça c'est vous avez annoncé et la case et
c b1
alors c'est pas folichon mais où la tour
à 8 tout de suite avait déjoué par
alberto david évidemment y met la
pression tout de suite sur le pion à 2
ouais alors tout à l'heure ce qu'il y
avait dans cette position c'est que la
colonne à pouvaient être exploités par
les noirs et la colonne essais
pourraient être exploitées par les
blancs qui avaient la tour c est
maintenant à toi est à partir d un c'est
les noirs qui vont utiliser la colonne
ouverte à leur profit la colonne a donc
d'où le dernier coup d'oeil avait dit à
la fois le clou pour cavaliers de un
double objectif à la fois de défendre à
deux et en même temps de libérer le
fouet fin qui va peut-être pouvoir se
développer en restant il pare au plus
pressé en défendant bon détroit en
défendant la casa 2 et le pion à deux
qui étaient menacées leur pend détroit
parce qu ici six attaques et des 4 mais
bon ces cavaliers sens pas très heureux
les cavaliers qui censurent la première
leur rôle ne peut être que purement
défensif or dès les cavaliers doivent
être utilisés autre chose en général
qu'à défense et les pièces d'attac idéal
ouais pour se sacrifier pourquoi est-ce
que ça fait des menaces ça fait pas
penser sa renault a une position à la
karpov un peu oui mais il est satisfait
deux sens entre ivoiriens
donné mais il a une position un peu on
va dire passive pour l'instant alors
qu'il était censé attaquer attaquer
voilà alors la merci de l'autre il a
l'air très précis puisque c'est un coût
qui fait pression sur des quatre voilà
johan benita a choisi de revenir en
trois avec la dame et alberto continue
d'attaquer avec eux cinq ils à la
faiblesse voilà alberto surtout il met
ses pions sur noir la prise il pas en
prendre du plomb à cause de tout reprend
foot eaux profondes en qu'il faut
reprendre des cavaliers aux dames du
cavalier sur l'anneau de saint lô des
cavaliers donc sans doute du cavalier
donc il joue quasiment instantanément il
va prendre du cavalier parce que la dame
n'est jamais un très bon bloqueur la la
case cinq blocs le pied en 4 et les
excellentes pour le cavalier parce que
si on joue f4 pour chasser ce cavalier
ce cavalier trouvera casey 4 on va
expliquer ont respecté pardon yoann
renault quand tu disais que la case la
case 2,5 et une classe de blocage par
rapport aux pieds en libre 4 ce pion ici
manière générale en bloc
puis en libre avec le meilleur des
bloqueurs qui est le cavalier la dame
étant le plus mauvais bloqueurs
puisqu'elle a une telle valeur on
comprendrait du cavalier comprend et du
cavalier et justement le pion des
disparus affirment des blancs on ne
craint pas trop la poussée f4 parce
qu'en récupérerai la casse g4 pour le
cavalier ils viennent receipts ateliers
d'art est ici attaque à la dame et puis
s'approchant du roi et trouvant une
belle occasion ils seraient actionnées
ce retraité actif sachant que les
ruptures à 9,5 et cetera à cause du duo
de pierre f 4 4 pourrait pas trop
exister à cause de la colonne e pour les
tours et le roi en vis à vis voilà voilà
la colonne alors on va remontrer ce sous
thèmes aussi tu vois tu vois un peu vite
renault donc on va on va ré expliquer
effectivement donc il ya aussi le fait
que si on joue f4 on affaiblit
du coup la case de 4 donc aussi la
colonne eux voilà et une tour ici aurait
appris à la fois sur le pied de 4 la
dame 3 et lawrence qui fait beaucoup
quand même deux choses qui permettrait
d'envisager des sacrifices en leucate
des poussées centrale et tout un tas de
choses
qui pourrait être très très dommageable
pour les blancs donc comme les prends
clan qui l'a vu prendre du cavalier
s'attendait peut-être pas à l'heure tous
les réfléchir certains n'hésitaient pas
à ce que comprend 1,5 que wes et ses
quatre mois se jouent à me la jouer tout
de suite et yoann benita puis on prend
le savez même pas réfléchi à fout d'eux
donc corps ça c'est le signe très
certainement que les blancs vont faire
le petit rock dans la foulée 2 mai
petits repères le pire h4 non ah oui
c'est vrai question ici à tati c'est pas
évident d'abriter le roi maintenant
alors à tout à l'heure il a dû hésiter
david apprendre la dame parce que dame
prend 1,5 attaqué le pion b2 qui était
défendu par personne weeds sommes ici
dans prend attaqué le pur b2dix mais bon
il a pris du cavalier ce qui est plus
normal et puis maintenant il va essayer
de travailler avec son avance de
développement parce qu'il a quand même
une avance de développement les tours
blanches sans palier les cavaliers le
non une avance les loin et une amende et
votre wii
à noter renault aussi d'une possibilité
souvent on peut mettre le roi à l'abri
mais là ça marcherait pas si on mettait
le roi et c'est ce que
je parlais que j'en parlais tout à
l'heure en début de partie dans ce type
de position le roi reste au centre dès
que ça s'ouvre alors les abris sont
difficiles qu'est-ce qui se passe
renault sur wave 2 si les blancs mais
dit on va sortir laurent ramener la
trouve à san siro à deux il ya une
combinaison naturel puisque le le pion
f3 trouve cloué dans lequel on va
expliquer autrement le clouage voilà ici
la dame d'amour et le tour et aurait
trouvé le pion voilà et le cavaliere g4
hors effet les los ché tombera d'hab on
aurait fait échec au roi à la fois
j'aurais fait un échec au roi et la dame
était ici qu'on aurait gagné la dame en
fait tout simplement le pion ne pouvant
pas bouger à cause de la dame et 6 voilà
mais il a choisi d'en échec au roi ici
beaucoup de flèches mais mais de toute
façon il n'est pas tombé dans le piège
et yoann il a joué un coup tranquille il
a joué damas mais ils préparent ils
pression qui prépare le petit rouquin
parce que là maintenant d'un mec de ils
protègent leur lâche 4 et donc il
prépare sans doute
enfin le petit rock et il aurait trouvé
finalement parce que moi une position
relativement correct mais on a
l'impression que c'est les noirs qui
sortent gagnants de cette ouverture il
est noir on va dire mieux réussi leur
ouverture
ils ont une seule pièce passive et pas n
est pas extraordinaire c'est le cavalier
h7
bon il faudrait peut-être qu'il améliore
son cavalier accepte en jouant cavalier
huit cavaliers 6 puis cavaliers des
quatre où cavaliers f4 un jour un papa
tant que c'est impossible mais qu'il
améliore ce cavalier quoi
voilà je couvre un peu le temps
puisqu'on est passé en seconde qu'on
peut le voir neuf minutes 50 secondes
pour yoann benita on est en dessous des
10 minutes et c'est à alberto david de
jouer il reste un peu plus de dix
minutes qui réfléchit qui a donc on peut
dire là où quand même dire renault puis
il ya il ya un clair avantage
ouais moi je pense que la position noir
est plus agréable à jouer
ils ont des meilleures pièces et donc
une pièce un peu passive lent que ce
cavalier h7 mais leurs autres pièces
sens en très bonne voie la fois aux six
avec l'idée de gagner un pion simplement
acquis même si on perd le fou contre le
cavalier on attaque le pion à 2 ans
gagne un pion donc il faut sanaa il faut
ça d'occuper avec la tour 1 8 le pion à
donner tant défendu qu'une fois par le
câble et c'est un donc une défense
possible pour les blancs mais le couple
et trois ans et les trois c'est le seul
coup pour défendre ça descendait le pion
à deux coeurs mais cela fragilise encore
plus le pion à dégoûter 5
alors attention cas prévu
alors la question qu'on peut se poser
aux noces ou plus des 5 complètement
inattendu qu'est ce qui se passe sur qui
on prend le coup des cinq d'un coup
intéressant parce que le roi est quand
même heureux 1
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle les rayons x
la tour alors limite la tour 8 vise le
roi blanc vin blanc vers un certain
nombre de pièces qui ne demande qu'à se
découvrir pour faire des combinaisons
donc il est prêt à donner un pion par ce
que il al'avantage développement le roi
est attardé au centre ouvrir les lignes
et
je revis des simples renault simplement
surpris on prend des 50 jours f5 dans le
câble est bien où va le cavalier est
menacée si le cavaliere en d2 un an je
pensais accueilli des trois ici mais non
ne marche pas il ya encore le cavalier
ici qui pourrait prendre beaucoup de
flèches encore en tout cas beaucoup de
combinaisons du fait que la tour 8 est
maintenant au centre où la bewan il a eu
peur d'ouvrir les lignes qu'il a joué
cavalier d2b il a intérêt à ne pas
ouvrir les lignes on dit que les lignes
ouvertes toute ouverture de ligne
profite essentiellement aux joueurs le
mieux développé donc le joueur le mieux
développé c'est lenoir surnombre les
lignes ça sera on ne peut penser à
l'avantagé du joueur noir donc ici
benita essai de d'installer le cavalier
à 9,4 en cas de prise donc comme prise
il va faire cavaler prendre oui et son
cavalier serez puissances et entre dans
qu'il recule la dame ans de manière à un
jour prendre 24 et à pouvoir jouer
peut-être être simple pour chasser ce
cavalier toujours exploité la colonne e
f ou alors aussi on nous révèle et le
catholique excentré l'un améliorée sans
sa mauvaise pièce à la cei en profite
yoann pour ok go benita et ils jouent
effectivement alberto david ramène son
câble et vers le centre est donc là ils
tiennent bien la casse des cinq et il
fait pression sur le but en 4 toujours
avantage noir on va dire toujours avoir
le tage noir plus dynamiques grosse
pression au centre pose et yes inconnu
coordonnées positionne plus libre un peu
puissant moral et si une grosse pas pris
ici mais bon à tout moment les blancs
est là encore revenir dans la partie et
bien évidemment après les prises à 2,4
lacasse g4 sera accessible wade et sur
pièce en pièce noire ce serait très
agréable pour les blancs de tolérer un
cavalier j'écarte il faut sans doute le
prendre et donner donner le fou cases
blanches ne serait pas forcément une
mauvaise nouvelle alors c'est toujours
intéressant de regarder les grands
maîtres jouer parce que il en un
les perceptions exceptionnelle de
l'agencement et la coordination des
pièces donc on apprend beaucoup en les
regardant jouer
alors est-ce que tu avais suivi la
victoire de johan benita à l'open des 20
g laujac j'étais passé à l'autre l'open
des verts l'an dernier pendant qu'il
faisait le tournoi et j'avais vu qu'ils
étaient bien partis pour gagner ce
tournoi qui marchait bien il marchait
bien
bon alors là le noir et le blanc a
refusé donc de donner la casse g4 et il
a pris en d5 pour lui-même récupéré la
case 4 pour pour son cavalier
parce que ce cavalier pour être chassés
de la case 4 c'est le coût f5 qui peut
le chasser le coeff s'inquiète un coût
qui n'est pas neutre
ce coup là c'est d'amener blairer a fait
dès lors la position du roi noir
donc il vaut mieux pas évités même si
c'est un affaiblissement à long terme
ouais avant collée mais le met vite et
ça alors les champs je suis en d5 à
simplifier un peu le centre ombre que
les noirs ont davantage son travail sont
deux bons cavaliers entre infosys bien
placé contre la casse des 5 et une
batterie ici de pièces lourdes
donc c'est pour ça que yoann mais sa
tour voyez mes bas rhin où il a mis sa
toile pour refaire un espèce de rio rixe
sur la dame c'est le voilà c'est lui qui
prend un peu maintenant l'initiative de
ce côté là alors qu en c3 voilà une
belle case une belle case pour le
cavalier intéressant le fameux attaque à
deux le fameux cavaliers en troisième
pour les noirs comme la foux ces quatre
là très vite très bien joué de la part
johan benita qui contre attaque en
jouant le kung fu c4 est intéressant
puisque si les noirs prennent et bien
après cavaliers français 4 on voit que
le club des cinq a du mal il est cloué
ici par la tour et le cas où les c4 fait
pression dessus c'est très très chaud
donc là il ya eu un transfert c'était le
noir qui mettait pression sur la colonne
et en quelques coups wilko poulains de
belhout à inverser la tendance c'est lui
maintenant qui fait pression sur cette
colonne eux voilà on l'a prise prise et
on voit que par miracle maintenant la
voilà et protège ici le pion voilà il
sort il sort la dame du visa bijoux
d'ahmed 6
on est très jolie le défense latérale
donc maintenant le cavalier protège à 2
et la dame aussi donc deux défenseurs et
deux attaquants pour ce pion voyez-vous
quand on en quelques coups par des
menaces centrale comment ivan benito
s'en est sorti il a très bien joué cette
passe de coulon impression voilà là
position s'est inversé la tendance un
peu c'est légèrement réquilibrer mêler
les noirs exerce quand même la pression
la pression est exercée par les noirs et
arrose échec en général c'est le joueur
le plus fort le mieux classé qui aiment
pas une pression quelque part sur
l'échiquier la dame noire fait pression
sur h4 lecavalier c3 fait pression sur
a2 alors on va montrer ce cavalier oui
ce cahier très bien placé évidemment
puisqu'il non seulement il fait pression
sur a2 il peut plus tard aussi faire des
menaces et les échecs au roi et aussi
les biens protégés par le plan b 4-1 qui
est donc une case une case très très
bien pour ceux qui avaient laissé trois
très puissant donc dans cette situation
alors le dernier coup alors parce que ce
serait un oui c'est peut-être un petit
piège mais pas tomber dans huit ans
alberto oui lui il voulait a rejoint le
cavalier d2 revenir en voulait à 1,4
évidemment pour éviter ses alliés la
pièce noire la plus ahurissante le
fameux cavalier noir sur la troisième
donc échange des tours donc l'envoyer
comme il ya une simplification donc les
blancs et c'est de simplifier une
position où ils sont dominés
spatialement mondialement pour leur
entrée dans une finale plus peut-être
plus jouable plus facile à jouer le
problème d'une finale c'est que dès
qu'il y a des faiblesses
dans les deux camps non le joueur ne
pouvant capter qu'une faiblesse à la
fois c'est pas si grave que ça d'avoir
plusieurs faiblesses en finale si
l'adversaire a aussi plusieurs
faiblesses pendant qu'on s'occupe une
faible adversaire lui s'occupe de la
vôtre etc etc
donc ça compense on peut maintenant il
ya de bonnes chances
ono pour qu'on s'achemine vers une
partie nulle pas vraiment parce qu'il ya
encore horber des problèmes pour les
noirs pour les blancs avec ce pion h4 eh
bien il ya toujours des problèmes qui
empêchent 4 la dame f2 et passive elle
est obligée de défendre le pirate cadre
elle peut pas s'éloigner la dame noire
peut à tout moment partir quand elle
veut pour faire ce qu'elle veut la dame
blanche ne peut pas ne pas trop la passe
vers sinon elle va perdre le pion à bien
sûr que les c4 d'un coup des blancs
quand il essaie d'améliorer toujours ses
pièces bien sûr il améliore le cahier c4
alors voit pas trop il peut aller venir
ce cavalier à 9,5 pour revenir sur cette
case centrale ici au 5 mai après pour
les ou qu'est ce qui ferait un e 5
c'est le problème serait pas trop quoi
faire avec après peut-être donc toujours
avantage - avec ce que la malice et 3
quand même moi y placer un bien sûr il
vous fait attention aux blancs une
pénétration d'une tour noire pour
l'instant ça va il n'y a pas de problème
en d2 mais souvent les pénétrations sur
la deuxième rangée pour les noirs ou sur
la septième pour les blancs sont souvent
décisives
voilà donc tour au 5e temps des quatre
attaques la faiblesse le pirate quatre
attaques latérales ou comment les blancs
défendre ce plan car beaucoup comme j'ai
trois seraient affaiblissant mais est
peut-être nécessaire
comment défendre le pion h 4 voilà le
problème des blancs
car j'ai trois repas comment le défendre
alors le coup j'ai trois possibles mais
affaibli les cases blanches ce qui est
un bonheur pour flessel et puis à mais
aussi aussi la protection des rois et le
pion f3 voilà il le fait quand même
obligé sinon ils perdaient du matériel
sans compenser sans compensation c5 a
été jouée par à leur tour david très
vite donc le temps et de commence à être
important aussi parce qu'il reste quatre
minutes aux blancs contre 7 minutes 30
au noir à noter que c'est du ko n ya pas
de rajout de temps soit ils savaient pas
trop quoi faire de ceux de ce pur
arriérés la suppliant de se fiancer
et puis un jouet en c5 il défend la tour
des quatre donc il libère la dame
à trois ils libèrent la dame alors à 3 a
été joué par ewan bien gérer pour pour
yoann qui libère une de ses faiblesses
donc l'esprit prise prise alors
maintenant ses faiblesses contre
faiblesse le pion c'est faible chez les
noirs le pion b for attention
combinaison quand même talent fou aussi
aux six attaques fait pression sur b3
petite pression sur b3 mais peut-être
aussi surtout je pense
renault que maintenant que j'ai trois
étaient joués il veut jouer le fou en d5
notre ami alberto pour faire pression
sur f3 et sur cette grande finale de
deux nouveaux ils cherchent une autre
cible
or les cibles dans les structures de
pions sont toujours là mais non
finalement le pion limina tour mais
quand on est attaqué obligé la tour
était attaquée
camaïeu 3 donc là ton est encore attaqué
peut-être qu'il va récupérer la case f4
pour le cavalier en jouant cavalier g de
f4 puisque c'est une quasi idéale pour
le cavalier le 4 et le fou qui
attaquerait le faut et surtout parce que
c'est difficile de jouer j'ai cinq pour
le chasser donc c'est ce qui fait il
joue cavalier g2 pour améliorer sans
cents cavaliers pour le mettre ici donc
voilà ce qui en plus à les gérer la
pression sur f3 peu fait la dame et 6
ou la cave les dna tensions menacent la
dérive 2 ou vaste dame lame d'eau est
logique un peut-être il va y avoir dans
des cas très rares des quatre échecs
dames des quatre échecs
hu à l'ancien hommes et leurs doutes
attention qu'est ce qu'on va faire du
roi à noter que la dame des quatre ici
protège aussi le cavalier bleu roi je
devais été jouée par johan benita
logique n'y avait pas trop de solution
puisqu'elle cavaliers d un contrôle et
les cases d'être d'interception de
l'échec à cazaux 3 et la kz2 voilà donc
on n'avait pas trop le choix est
maintenant le cas il revient en c3 il le
travaille un peu court l'un ouais je
vous là il faut un peu la pendule j'ai
l'impression alberto d'un mini jeux vous
des coûts rapidement
évidemment c'est important puisque en
partie de 20 minutes la lionne benitez à
la pression attention enfin à accélérer
son rythme des lois 2 minutes 45
on est maintenant dans une phase blitz
donc les coûts et on peut noter que la
partie a quand même été joué à un bon
rythme un très bon rythme c'est rapide
dans benita et la droite opposition des
changes des dames les blancs essaie
d'alléger la pression oui pascal
berteaud va accepter sans doute pas que
petit jouet pour améliorer sa position
alberto david goyer un petit problème
aussi dans le déséquilibre des pièces
mineurs et les noirs on préserver un fou
et donc mais ils changent ils échangent
verte outre d'apprendre pourquoi allez
les noirs devant ça nous te faire
tourner deux peut-être n'ont qu'à
valider un cavalier d un attaque la tour
les noirs maintenant en faire confiance
à l'heure à leur fou qui est qui est
assez libre parce que je vois pas
l'intérêt de ce couple et d un cavalier
pas trop ce que veut faire le deuil ici
autant peut jouer un coup comme voilà
attendait 3 bien joué de la part de
yoann l'a quasiment obligeant les trois
forces forcer les contours et le pion
csn tombe fort l esprit rencontre le
pied en mai 3 voilà mais ça devrait donc
né vers une nulle donc voilà il y avait
il ya de fortes chances alentours des 4
dollars bien d'accord il ya de fortes
chances il refuse la nu le cadre des
changes les pièces lourdes la partie ce
soit cheminer vers vers une nulle c'est
pour ça qu'ils gardent encore la tour
voilà encore la tour pour essayer de
faire quelque chose joli coup ce tour
des quatre vit dans quoi de prison
reprend du pillon cavaliers f4 attaque
ils voudraient éliminer le fou établir
l'équilibré des pièces refus voilà que
la tour et attaquer maintenant par le
fou forçant peut-être les blancs à
prendre des quatre voies il le fait tris
prise donc voilà donc attention où là il
ne met tout de suite en avant il y avait
dit à son pion passé oui voilà bloqué
par alberto david pour l'empêcher
d'aller plus loin
alors maintenant on a la fameuse finale
quand ils les font cavalier qu'entre
deux cavaliers vous la ville n'avait pas
vu ça alberto sans doute voilà la série
puisqu'il perd le pion des quatre où la
même précision terrible la d'alberto
david aurait peut-être dû prendre la
nulle proposé implicitement période
bénite attention à 1042 contre 3 minutes
10 le le match là cette première partie
va rentrer dans une phase extrêmement
décisive ouais je pense que david
tiendra toujours là nul même si le père
et ses trois attention même s'il perd le
contention attention quand même
attention ce même si faire le pied en
était le temps va jouer
oui mais le temps de jouer aussi il peut
se passer un peu n'importe quoi avec
aussi peu de temps en plus il active
sans droit maintenant c'est incroyable
yoann benita a complètement retourné la
situation
y'a pas du tout à taez ville récupère a
décidément il ya des erreurs de il va
récupérer surtout les hôtesses qui l'aï
l'acte iv le roi de tous les côtés
maintenant seuls à mettre en place et il
prendra quand il voudra
non il est pas pressé pour le prendrais
pas vraiment et ça il n'y a pas vus
cavaliers ou cinq qui prend le turf 7
renault c'est quand même extraordinaire
ses erreurs à répétition dans cette
première partie beau retournement de
situation comme une lionne benita qui
devrait s'en sortir au moins avec la
nulle maintenant et action contre 2 je
pense qu'il va y avoir une partie nulle
mais les chances de gain à tension des
chances de gain de 6 à 4 non il va peut
être y voilà peut-être avec le temps
évidemment pas avec la rigueur et l
annuler
anon il a deux pions il ya de plus en
plus ouais mais il sans tension il le
prend de 6,5
il suffit de sacrifier les deux pièces
noires sur les deux pions ah oui mais
pas ici à roye et de cavaliers contre
rien n'est pas facile hein pas facile de
sacrifier dès qu'on sacrifie les pièces
sur les pillant on annule hall 6
maintenant attention renault ou l'axé
c'est ce qu'il va faire avec ali ou
celle qu'on lie avec un dessin qui gagne
est ici pouvait jouer là là là c'est
terrible je pense qu'il pourrait jouer
faux prend h7
qu'est-ce qui se passe oulalala
cavaliers de 6 la menace c'est qu'avec
g6 oui mais bien joué il valait g5
peut-être il faut vite ça la caisse qui
savent allier aux cinq échecs
roy a suite voilà ça devrait être
tranquille maintenant cavalier des huit
attaques le fou qui peut venir ici sans
doute et ont proposé avec la pièce sa
confiance et le kung fu et 4 ici il faut
être quatre annuler faut 4 annuler parce
que si les blancs prennent il suffit de
prendre le dernier pion et on peut pas
gagner voilà il le fait en deux coups
entre david voilà ça va être nul pour
essayer dans la cellule voilà sans doute
partie nulle voilà donc il y aura cinq
minutes de pause
et bien la partie s'est terminée par la
nullité
les deux joueurs se sont bien battus et
effectivement il n'y a plus de
possibilité de ghazni pour les places
c'était chaud
[Musique]